aufstand abgesagt die cdu-chefin drängt
ihre rivalen zurück zumindest für den
moment angst vor dem rauswurf in
stuttgart gehen 15.000 menschen auf die
straße um ihre jobs in der autobranche
zu retten generation bewegungsmuffel
vier von fünf jugendlichen bewegen sich
viel zu wenig mit folgen für die
gesundheit
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers sind einige der themen
in den kommenden zwanzig minuten guten
abend hinein schön dass sie dabei sind
sport nachher mit norbert ein stück von
mir
es ist nichts weniger als die machtfrage
die die cdu chefin da heute ganz offen
gestellt hat auf dem bundesparteitag in
leipzig annegret kramp karrenbauer hat
ihre innerparteilichen gegner
aufgefordert aus der deckung zu kommen
und ihren eigenen rückzug angeboten
falls sie für ihren kurs keine
unterstützung finden sollte am ende hat
es gewirkt die cdu revolution blieb aus
mathis feldhoff
es ist der moment in dem annegret kramp
karrenbauer realisiert dass ihr coup
aufgegangen ist in einer für die cdu
beispiellosen aktion zwingt sie die
partei ihr zu folgen mit einer
rücktrittsdrohung wenn ihr der meinung
seid dass dieser weg den ich gemeinsam
mit euch gehen möchte nicht der weg ist
den ihr für den richtigen halt dann
lasst es uns heute aussprechen und er
lasst es uns heute auch beenden hier und
jetzt und heute zuvor beschreibt sie was
sie für deutschland vorhat
zukunftstechnologien fördern mehr geld
für die bundeswehr ein gerechter
sozialstaat und sie rechnet mit ihren
kritikern ab ohne einen namen zu nennen
das nörgeln es müsse endlich aufhören
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie man so
wahlkampf machen will wenn man auf der
einen seite den bürgern sagt es war
alles schlecht was wir gemacht haben
aber wir wären schon froh wenn ihr euch
nochmal welt damit es auch noch 14 jahre
weitermachen können das ist keine
erfolgreiche wahlkampfstrategie rivale
friedrich merz muss sich heute
geschlagen geben einsturz der
parteivorsitzenden ist selbst für den
lautesten und der kramp karrenbauers
kritikern nicht denkbar
märz entscheidet sich für eine geste der
scheinbaren demut
und wir sind loyal zu unserer
vorsitzenden unserer parteiführung und
zur bundesregierung die wir seit über 50
jahren tragen und das waren gute jahre
für deutschland
die entscheidung über die
kanzlerkandidatur ist auf 2020 vertagt
es hat sich da sehr hohe messlatte
gelegt wie es auch viel zu erfüllen sie
hat es sehr stark gemacht und dann
konnte er natürlich nicht mehr so gut
noch einen gegenpol darstellen
sie hat einfach nach dem motto angriff
ist die beste verteidigung in der aus
gefordert und er hat von selbiger seite
da ist jetzt nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt die cdu erlebt heute
einmaliges und offenbart den druck unter
dem die vorsitzende steht noch öfter
kann kramp karrenbauer einen rücktritt
kaum androhungen spannender tag in
leipzig bringen wir matthias fornoff mit
dazu in die sendung matthias erst mal
vielleicht ganz kurz zum auftritt von
friedrich merz heute scheinbare demut
haben wir da gerade gehört war das heute
das ende der rivalität mit der chefin
oder behält er sich da doch noch einen
weiteren anlauf vor
naja es ist hier heute nicht zum großen
showdown gekommen obwohl kramp
karrenbauer die machtfrage ja gestellt
hat friedrich merz ist nicht in die
konfrontation gegangen im gegenteil er
hat seine loyalität betont und angeboten
mitzuarbeiten
das heißt aber noch lange nicht dass er
raus ist bei personalentscheidungen wie
etwa der kanzlerkandidatur im nächsten
jahr diese hintertür ist offen märz
bleibt in lauerstellung und kann die
parteichefin jetzt durchatmen hat sie
die partei wirklich voll hinter sich
nach einem jahr als cdu-chefin kam kramp
karrenbauer ziemlich angezählt nach
leipzig zu viele fehler zu viele
wahlniederlagen zu schlechte bewertungen
in den umfragen mit einer inhaltlich
starken rede hat sie die delegierten
hier überzeugt und merz und seine
anhänger auf distanz gehalten
damit sitzt sie tatsächlich fester im
sattel als zuvor
in der frage der kanzlerkandidatur kann
sie so zumindest mal das verfahren
besteht
hkk hat sich hier vertrauen erkämpft
aber das gilt wie meistens in der
politik nur auf bewährung
matthias danke für diese analyse die
machtfrage auf offener bühne wenn sie
noch mal reinhören wollen in die
wichtigsten reden auf dem cdu-parteitag
die kompletten wortbeiträge finden sie
bei uns online auf heute.de im bild
natürlich bleibt noch ein moment in der
innenpolitik schleswig-holstein legt
sich quer beim klima paket
regierungschef daniel günther von der
cdu will am kommenden freitag im
bundesrat nicht zustimmen weil länder
und gemeinden weniger steuern einnehmen
würden außerdem fordert er einen höheren
preis für den co2 verbrauch baden
württemberg will noch änderungen
durchsetzen jetzt ein drängendes problem
für deutschlands wichtigste branche und
damit für dieses land in der
autoindustrie knirscht es gewaltig es
droht ein massiver abbau von
arbeitsplätzen etwa 800 20.000
beschäftigte arbeiten zurzeit bei den
autobauern und ihren zulieferern
ein knappes viertel von ihnen produziert
motoren und getriebe noch denn die
zukunft soll ja den elektroantrieben
gehören dann wären diese arbeitsplätze
überflüssig das heißt rund 200.000
stellen stehen auf der kippe
die ig metall hat 15.000 demonstranten
auf die straße gebracht die einen fairen
wandel fordern aus stuttgart andreas
linke
es ist unsicherheit was die
demonstranten auf dem stuttgarter
schlossplatz und unsicherheit darüber
wie es in der branche weitergeht und ob
sie beim wandel mitreden können aber
einfach dass wir uns auch aktiv
einbringen können die beschäftigte wir
werden oft vor vollendete tatsachen
gestellt das ist die wahre welt im
moment bleiben um das mitgestalten geht
es der gewerkschaft die
herausforderungen denen sich die
automobilbranche stellen muss sieht sie
auch dieser wandel wird kommen und er
muss kommen
er kündigt einfach zugucken und die welt
dreht sich weiter sondern es geht darum
wie wir den wandel gestalten doch die
zeitungsschlagzeilen der vergangenen
wochen deuten darauf dass der wandel
schon längst begonnen hat
ohne mitsprache es werde zu schnell die
jobs sense ausgepackt sagt die
gewerkschaft und deshalb ist der weg
denn jetzt einige wählen leute
rauszuschmeißen und einseitig zur kasse
zu bitten der falsche wege und deshalb
sind wir heute auf der straße die
arbeitgeber fühlen sich durch den
aktionstag provoziert und kritisieren
die scharfe wortwahl der gewerkschaft
wir sind zu einer zusammenarbeit bereit
das geht nur um diese transformation
gelingt nur wenn wir als sozialpartner
zusammenarbeiten und da bringt es nichts
auf die straße zu gehen und den menschen
vorzumachen dass alles so bleibt wie es
ist denn es wird nicht alles so bleiben
wie es ist
dafür lösungen zu finden mit denen alle
gut leben können das wird eine
schwierige aufgabe und die suche hat
gerade erst begonnen
noch eine riesen branche die
chemieindustrie 580.000 menschen
arbeiten dort und für die gibt es jetzt
einen tarifabschluss plus 1,5 prozent
mehr geld ab mitte nächsten jahres und
ein jahr später noch mal 1,3 prozent
mehr also eher geringe zuwächse für eine
erfolgs branche aber die gewerkschaft
setzte auch eine zusätzliche
pflegeversicherung für die beschäftigten
durch ibrahim iri serienverbrecher
führendes mitglied eines libanesischen
clans war vor vier wochen nach
deutschland eingereist illegal denn die
deutschen behörden hatten ihn eigentlich
im sommer in den libanon abgeschoben
sein neuer asylantrag ist bereits
abgelehnt und heute entschied das bremer
verwaltungsgericht endgültig dass er
sofort wieder abgeschoben werden kann
und jetzt ein thema das durchaus einiges
sagt über unsere gesellschaft in
arnsdorf in sachsen wirft die
bürgermeisterin das handtuch monate lang
wird martina angermann spd von
rechtsextremen angefeindet und
eingeschüchtert sie erkrankt und
beantragt vorzeitig ihren ruhestand
was ist passiert 2016 war alsdorf in die
schlagzeilen geraten weil eine
selbsternannte bürgerwehr einen
psychisch kranken gak fesselte aus
notwehr wie sie sagten der mann soll die
kassiererin eines supermarktes bedroht
haben
die bürgermeisterin verurteilte diesen
zwischenfall scharf und geriet damit
selbst in den fokus des hasses jetzt
zeigt sich die sächsische spd entsetzt
und bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht spricht von einem angriff auf
unsere demokratie
acht tage noch dann wissen wir für
welches führungsduo sich die
spd-mitglieder entschieden haben das
thema in der partei derzeit auch heute
beim juso bundeskongress in schwerin
dabei geht es nicht nur ums personal
sondern auch um die zukunft der groko
der stehen die jusos und ihr
vorsitzender kevin kühnert ja äußerst
kritisch gegenüber bernd mosebach
berichtet aus schwerin
es geht ums ganze um das weltklima den
weltfrieden und die zukunft der großen
koalition in berlin
bundeskongress der jungsozialisten sie
sehen sich als antreiber der spd drängen
auf mehr sozialstaat mehr einfluss in
ihrer partei und sie wollen raus aus der
regierung mit der union
wir wollen dass die spd aus der neben
dem rein pampa rauskommt und das
glaubwürdig mit ihren gesichtern auch
unterfüttern die wir genossen und
genossen kevin kühnert kündigt erneut an
auf dem bundesparteitag in zwei wochen
für den bundesvorstand zu kandidieren
die delegierten feiern ihn dafür in
schwerin kein leichter stand für
bundesumweltministerin schulze eine
regierung mit den grünen wäre zwar
leichter für sie dennoch an
regierungsbündnis hält sie fest
wenn es nach dem spd nachwuchs geht
sollen saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans die spd künftig führen beide
eher links beide kritiker der großen
koalition
ich glaube nicht dass die große
koalition das potenzial hat um die
richtigen entscheidungen und weil ihnen
die großen entscheidungen zu treffen
also kevin ist seit zwei jahren das
gesicht von no go und wenn er dort
eingeführt wird dann wird heiß zugehen
eine partei im umfragetief mit einer
jugendorganisation die selbstbewusst
druck macht am abend soll der
vorsitzende wiedergewählt werden an den
gegenkandidaten gibt es nicht
und jetzt eine reportage aus einem
gebiet in europa in dem seit fünf jahren
ein krieg tobt mit bislang rund 13.000
toten
jetzt gibt es immerhin so etwas wie
einen neuen anlauf für eine
diplomatische lösung
der russische und der ukrainische
präsident wollen in drei wochen
miteinander reden das ist ein kleiner
erfolg der vermittlungsbemühungen des
westens und nur möglich weil sich an
einzelnen stellen der über 400 kilometer
langen frontlinie beide seiten
zurückziehen die regierungstruppen und
die prorussischen rebellen zurück
bleiben ihnen angst und kriegsmüde
aus dem grenzort loma kino berichtet
christian sie ist ein kräftiger eisiger
wind das piepsen des suchgerät kaum zu
hören jedes mal könnte es eine mine sein
sie machen einen gefährlichen und
wichtigen job die minenräumer in der ost
ukraine
wir machen die welt besser es ist mein
land
wenn ich es sauberer und sicherer machen
kann bedeutet mir das sehr früh panzer
im inland mit schafen blindgänger auf
diesem feld liegt einiges rum was
menschen verletzen oder töten könnte
die ukrainische armee hatte die minen
hier zu beginn des krieges ausgelegt um
die stadt mariupol zu verteidigen und
einen kilometer ist die alte frontlinie
von diesem minenfeld hier entfernt
libyen räume müssen jetzt die spuren des
krieges hier beseitigen jede gelbe
markierung hier bedeutet dass dort mal
eine mine war
wir sind unterwegs an der frontlinie und
treffen menschen die gezeichnet sind vom
krieg als age co hat gekämpft für die
ukrainische armee einen lungenflügel
hatte dabei verloren
jetzt studiert der politik und hatte
eine pizza und kaffeekette gegründet die
vor allem ex soldaten und flüchtlinge
anstellt von den kommenden
friedensverhandlungen hält er nichts
ich habe im krieg viele freunde verloren
gebiete verloren die ich nie wieder
gehen kann
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass in
zukunft leute durch meine stadt durch
mein land laufen die auf mich geschossen
und meine freunde und tötet habe frieden
aber zu welchem preis diese frage
stellen sich hier viele und an der front
wird währenddessen weiter beobachtet und
geschossen
[Applaus]
und an dieser stelle in der sendung
heute abend eine studie die aufrütteln
soll im wahrsten sinne des wortes
jugendliche bewegen sich zu wenig sagt
die weltgesundheitsorganisation mehr als
anderthalb millionen 11 bis 17 jährige
wurden befragt und das rund um die welt
das ergebnis mädchen sind besonders
große bewegungsmuffel die übergroße
mehrheit fast 88 prozent sind
hierzulande weniger als eine stunde am
tag körperlich aktiv bei den jungs nicht
viel besser dort sind rund 80 prozent
nicht mal eine stunde täglich in
bewegung
gründe dafür und die folgen hat david
sauer
früher war mehr bewegung das erzählen
eltern gern und es stimmt sagt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
oft ist es eine frage von prioritäten
smartphone versus sportplatz aber
manchmal fehlt auch einfach die zeit
ich würde gerne mehr machen aber es
funktioniert manchmal leider nicht wegen
schule und arbeit lässt sich das leider
nicht so wirklich vereinbaren kann halt
auch morgens nicht wirklich die
motivation dann ich weiß nicht joggen zu
gehen oder so was das ist schlecht
bewegung macht nämlich nicht nur gesund
sondern auch sozial sagen experten
sie müssen auch mal gewinnen und
verlieren so wie im sport und bewegung
ist einfach ein mittel dafür ohne dass
geht's nicht wie es mit bewegung geht
macht die profilschule im finnischen
seiner jacke seit jahren vor zum
beispiel in mathe wer falsch rechnet
muss rennen und selbst in bio geht es
nur mit einer turnübung welche sind die
drei wichtigsten körperlichen
veränderungen bei jungs in der pubertät
muskeln wachsen am körper wachsen haare
das dritte weiß ich nicht mehr
die studie beklagt auch einen
geschlechterunterschied mädchen bewegen
sich im schnitt weniger als jungs weil
die aktivitäten oft auf jungs
zugeschnitten sind deshalb sollten
länder und schulen angebote machen die
speziell auch mädchen anspricht
mehr angebote das wäre auch in
deutschland gut sagt die whu zum
beispiel könnten pausenhöfe auch nach
schulschluss geöffnet bleiben das ziel
in zehn jahren soll die zahl der
bewegungsmuffel auf unter 70 prozent
fallen und für jede menge bewegung zähle
ich jetzt auf dich haben sie auf jeden
fall der ball rollt ja auch wieder in
der fußball bundesliga nach zwei wochen
länderspielpause in der die
abstiegsbedrohten vereine aus mainz und
köln ihre trainer feierten und neue
anheuerten achim beierlorzer und markus
gisdol keine unbekannten gesichter in
der bundesliga markus gisdol in köln und
achim beierlorzer in mainz geben am
wochenende ihren einstand bei neuen
vereinen größerer umbruch beim fc hier
gesellt sich neben dem trainer mit horst
heldt als geschäftsführer sport ein
neuer leitender angestellter hinzu ich
weiß aus eigener erfahrung dass der
mannschaft sicher wohl fühlen muss in
dem was man ihnen vorgibt vorgabe schon
wichtig und trotz alledem müssen sie
sich wiedererkennen
damit sie ist halt auch dann
dementsprechend gut umsetzen können
samstag 18 30 muss sich das geißbock
team bei den bullen aus leipzig zur wehr
setzen
mainz-trainer beierlorzer trifft auf
hoffenheim genau also jenes team das
seine entlassung vor knapp zwei wochen
durch einen sieg in köln mit verursachte
nun hoffen sie in mainz dass er daraus
gewinnbringende erkenntnisse gewonnen
hat weltranglisten zweite novak djokovic
und das serbische tennisteam sind bei
der davis cup endrunde in madrid im
viertelfinale ausgeschieden durch eine 1
2 niederlage gegen russland
die entscheidung wie viel in einem hoch
dramatischen doppel überschäumende
freude beim russischen team
hauchdünne siege sind einfach die
emotionalsten vor allem wenn sie gegen
absolute weltstars wie novak djokovic
gelingen
im einzel hatte sich der superstar noch
glatt gegen karin katchalov durchgesetzt
im doppel aber macht es ihm der mann mit
der blauen kappe wesentlich schwerer
gemeinsamen anträge oplev setzt er die
serben djokovic und jackie immer wieder
unter druck und übernimmt nach abwehr
eines matchballes bei 88 im tiebreak des
entscheidenden satzes die initiative
ausgerechnet djokovic mit dem fehler der
russland match ball bringt und den
nutzen die ohne ihren spitzenspieler
medwedew angetretenen russen zum
hochemotionalen einzug ins
davis-cup-finale
ja und dem viertelfinale zwischen
deutschland großbritannien hat gerade
philipp kohlschreiber das auftaktspiel
gegen kanada und verlogen
vielen dank norbert wird trotzdem wirkt
er noch zwei spiele und wir haben noch
ein geburtstagskind jetzt in der sendung
nämlich diesen kerl hier ein geschichten
erzähler im fernsehen heute vor sechs
jahrzehnten war der kleine mann mit
zipfelmütze und spitzbart zum ersten mal
in der damaligen ddr zu sehen mit seinem
guten nacht gruß
[Musik]
60 jahre jung und immer noch mit dem
berühmten glitzernden sand unterwegs
damit jeden abend mehr als eine million
kleiner zuschauer gut träumen können die
kinder mögen vor allem seine beständig
freundliche art sagen die macher katja
horne vorhat freundliche nachrichten vom
wetter am wochenende gibt es mehr sonne
das ist doch was um 22 uhr hat claus
kleber das heute-journal und freut sich
wenn sie dabei sind wir danken herzlich
für ihr interesse heute gerne bis morgen
vom gesamten heute 19 team in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genommen meine damen und herren nicht
nur auf den bergen konnten sie heute die
sonne genießen wie zum beispiel hier im
harz oder auch im sauerland nehmen nicht
die sonne gab es auch im südwesten jetzt
in der nacht ist die spannende frage wo
ist es denn kalt genug für glätte
das ist südlich des thüringer weil es
der fall da sinken die temperaturen auf
+2 bis -3 grad deutlich milder bleibt
die nach dem nordosten bei 7 bis 4 grade
sie kann den wolken und auch morgen gibt
es eine region wo ist doch
wahrscheinlich den ganzen tag über trüb
bleibt nämlich zwischen der lüneburger
heide und im emsland ist der wind
einfach nicht stark genug an der küste
aber da zeigt sich häufiger die sonne
ganz anders sieht es am alpenrand aus da
bläst erfüllen und der bringt sehr viel
sonnenschein mit und so steigen dort die
temperaturen morgen auf 13 bis 16 grad
auch sonst ist es recht mild mit sieben
bis zwölf grad und mit sonnenschein und
nebel und wolken geht es auch am sonntag
weiter bei 7 bis 14 grad dann kommt die
neue woche und das wetter ändert sich
etwas denn von westen kommen regen
wolken heran
dabei bleibt es aber mild bei 5 bis 12
grad
schönes wochenende